now it isn't just the Democrat
politicians turning on their own
constituents it's the Democrat Law
Enforcement Officers supported by
Democrat activist cash
radical Soros back Massachusetts U.S
attorney Rachel Rollins is resigning
after a lengthy doj Watchdog
investigation revealed that she not only
unethically attended a partisan Biden
fundraiser but she lied under oath about
leaking sensitive doj information to the
media to try to help a Democrat win
elected office
now so not only was she coddling
criminals but unethically supporting
politicians in the process of course all
liberal it's a double whammy now it's
shocking how no one saw how radical how
corrupt how pathetic she was from the
very beginning
at what point did you decide to run for
district attorney
I was really tired of turning the TV on
and seeing an incident involving law
enforcement where overwhelmingly black
male comes in contact with
overwhelmingly white male officer and
people were losing their lives
joining me now is Arkansas Senator Tom
Cotton he sits on the Senate Judiciary
Committee and has been a vocal opponent
of Rachel Rollins since 2021
Senator she's just one person one D.A
but you warned about her from the start
how many Rachel Rollins uh people like
her who think like her who conduct
themselves like her do you think could
be out there
well Laura I'm afraid a lot of them are
out there we know there's a lot of Soros
prosecutors like Rachel Rollins in
Boston or Larry krasner Philadelphia
George cascone in La she was the first
to be elevated by Joe Biden to the
position of the U.S attorney I warned 18
months ago that she wasn't just a
radical procriminal audio log but she
had a history of ethical lapses and bad
judgment in fact we insisted that we had
recorded votes both in the Judiciary
Committee and on the senate floor for
this U.S attorney nominee the first time
that it happened in 28 years and the
Democrats moaned and wailed and
complained we're obstructionists what
they should have done is taken a closer
look at her record because now they bear
responsibility for the fact that she has
resigned in disgrace that she committed
so many ethical violations in office in
Boston that the inspector General
referred her for criminal prosecution
yet what did Merrick Garland do in just
three weeks he declined to prosecute her
for lying to investigators but if it's
Michael Flynn or if it's congressman
Fortenberry or if it's Steve Bannon he's
more than happy to pursue his party's
political opponents for lying charges or
other process charges just another
example of the of the double standard
that Merrick Garland has when it comes
to law enforcement oh yeah yeah they
have the Zeal to go after someone like
abandon of course but Senators Marky and
Warren uh your colleagues apparently
they don't care about any of this
they're standing with Rollins their
statement that they released reads in
part Rachel Rollins has for years
dedicated herself to the people of
Massachusetts and equal justice under
the law senator
it's official I mean standards the
dignity that Biden promised that's all
out the window it's about raw power for
these people
and I think a lot of the reasons why
those Democrats stood by Rachel Rollins
even after we raised those red flags so
much so that it took Kamala Harris
coming in and breaking a tie vote for a
mere U.S attorney position is that she's
part of the George Soros left-wing
activist network of anti-law enforcement
activists around the country that throws
around so much money and so much
political weight in their party no one
was willing in the Democratic party was
willing to cross this pro-crime powerful
network of left-wing activists
Senator cotton it's I mean I'd say it's
surprising but sadly it's all too
predictable uh and it must stop we must
stop it Senator thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else